third start for carlos carrasco since
coming back from a hamstring injury that
cost him nearly four months
getting stretched out and trying to
become an important piece of the metro
rotation heading down the stretch which
was the plan all along you know gary
it's going to be interesting to see his
pitch usage
29 of his 62 pitches against miami were
sliders he went to that
early and often 88 career wins
all with the cleveland indians
well how about this
juan soto back in the starting lineup
and the table is set he'll stand in to
face carlos carrasco for the first time
ever and that ball driven out to left
center see
you
later bang zoom goes sono
a line shot right over the 370 foot
marker
and into the picnic area in left center
field
[Applause]
so much for the
homeless streak in the rbi streak they
both go away after 11 games juan soto
with his 19th home run rbi's 59
60 and 61. and it's the nationals three
and that's nothing so a great at-bat by
victor robles and a high fastball cities
escobar lays down a beautiful bun juan
soto who owns new york
continues to own new york so can paolo
espino take advantage of a big time
struggling new york offense these are
still some good major league hitters
that p and pablo is going to have to be
good yeah 34 years old last time out
maybe his worst start of the year so
we're not going to talk about that 9-5
loss last time against the phillies
so alonso in scoring position with two
after dom smith who had one for eight in
philadelphia he gets a curveball and
drills it out to right field soto goes
back to the wall and bounces up against
the fence
alonzo comes in to score tom smith
trading places back-to-back doubles for
alonso and smith and the mets get on the
board it's now three to one well soto
either just assumed that ball was going
over the fence or thought he would get a
livelier karen than he did it was a
hangar all right from espino but that
ball didn't even make it to the fence on
the fly it hit on the warning track i
wonder if the wind had something to do
with that because he hit it 103 miles an
hour off the bat so it was well struck
by dominic smith but it strangely did
not carry very much well those are the
clouds that are gathering up above the
uh left field fence they're going to
cover the field right now they got they
got to cover it you saw the thumbs up
from bill deacon the head groundskeeper
saying it's time to come we were
stopping at 7 42 last night we resume at
4 12 today exactly 20 and a half hours
riley adams into scoring position so now
victor robles and robles swings and hits
one of the air to deep left field moving
dominic smith back has a play on the
warning track and missed the ball up
against the wall so rounding third is
riley adams coming to the plate and the
throw will not be in time fo blaze all
the way over to third now on the play
dominic smith drifted four kept going
back fourth and could not haul in up
near the base of the wall in left field
so adam scored easily robles with an rbi
double taking third on the throw home
and it's four to one national that was
not a good decision by jonathan vr dom
smith had his glove on that ball and it
bounced off and slightly away from him
but vr had no chance to get adams at
home through it home and that allowed
roblox to get all the way over clearance
the third double of this game for the
minutes they'll follow jeff mcneal who
bats here mcneal lines one
and it's everywhere for a base hit
nipple reddit well he'll score easily
jeff mcneal with an rbi single to get
the match closer it's now 4-2 washington
26 rbi for jeff mcneil
tore the handle of his band just floated
it over the head of the second baseman
garcia in the right field
ammo taking off he was able to make you
without a throw in the match with
back-to-back hits and a run to start the
third inning mcneill at third base now
the tying run alonso at second how
michael conforto's the batter poorno
it's a bouncer first base side this will
score a run bell has it left flip to
first with ross covering for the out
mcneil comes home the mets are down just
one now
when porno gets an rbi it's four to
three washington and pete alonzo takes
third on the pledge and now the tying
run at third with two out for jd davis
that slide toward left field that'll get
it done a base hit it bounces to the
wall alonso scores jd davis takes off
for second he's tied the game with an
rbi double and it's four to four here in
the third luis garcia the batter four
for the score top of the fifth runners
first and third nobody out well look at
that
extra base hit indeed
it'll one hop the wall with right center
daddy hernandez scoring kibum coming
around
in there in plenty of time double to
right center field for luis garcia
driving home two
it's now the national six in the mets
four on a two run double by luis garcia
right-handed hitting rookie catcher
riley adams with luis garcia leading off
second adam swings it's a ground ball
through it to center field to base it
rounding third is garcia he's coming
home to score the throw from nimmo will
go into second base
the nationals have played it three runs
now here at the top of the fifth innings
adams drives in his third run
of the year for the nationals and it's
now washington seven new york four porto
did drive in a run in his last at bat
with a ground out 3-2 pitch that's
ripped into right field base hit
chasing toward the line and soto around
second heading to third is mcneal he's
going to be waved around
now the throw to the plate not in time
to throw down the second they have
conforto caught between first and second
bell is going to chase him back and
comporter was tagged out by bell for the
final out but the mets do get a run
mcneil does score and so now baez will
come to bat if the pinch hitter will be
the tying run at the plate perfect spot
for him swinging a miss he got him on a
slider a foot outside
baez with a bit of a grimace as he walks
back toward the dugout he strikes out on
three pitches alonzo two for three a
double single and a flyout on the
afternoon global sits at the set the
pitch line center field deep back goes
well bless he looks up and it's off the
wall in play digging for third nimmo
he's going to be waved around the relay
throw to the plate will not be in time
alonzo with an rbi double at second the
mets have trimmed it to one now seven to
six nationals and the nets have the
tying run in scoring position to begin
the bottom of the eighth inning now
jonathan vr will be the batter seven to
six washington has the lead vr squares
gets the bunt down this will advance him
down the line and the mitch will tie the
game
davis comes in to score
thompson had plenty of time a sidearm
sling to first and he whizzed it right
by josh bell davis scoring the tying run
easily the go-ahead run 90 feet away as
brandon drury pinch hits for trevor man
and drury bloops one
base hit and the vets take the lead he
just got enough of it to get it over
garcia and into the outfield brandon
drury gets the go-ahead hit
and the mets are in front for the first
time in a week so diaz after striking
out soto gets bell on one pitch and the
nats are down to their final out
grounded down to first and it's fair
ball spread by smith and the goal game
is over and the mets get themselves a
much needed respite as they snap a
four-game losing streak by beating the
gnats eight
to seven